THREE-GAME SEGMENT BEATING
DALLAS AND THEE SHARKS AND THE ,
THE FIRST OF DEFLECTED AS HE IS
LIVE HERE.
AND FEHR RATRRARO, HE HAS A HIGY
UP FOR COGLIAN 22.
BACKHAND
>> Randy: TIMO BARABANOV
ROBERTSON BACK ACROSS.
AND THE STARS NOW LOOK TO
EQUALIZEENTER.
>> Bret: NOAH GREGOR WENT INE N.
TWO GAMES REIMERD FORCED IALEX
PENALTY, AND ROBERTSON FINDS BAN
BACK TO THGROUP?
>> Bret: HE WANTED A BETTER
START.
DIDN'T GET IT.G COGLIANO, AND H.
I DON'T THINK -- IT GOES RIGHT .
TIED UP BYA TICK
YOU HAVE PENALTY, AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THEY HAV SEGUIN.
HE WILL TAKE IT BACK FOR THE ATY
PAVELSKI, AN Bret: ONE OF THE BS
FOR THE SHARKS KARLSSON.
HE SCORES!U SEE HIS FOOT
MAKING THE PASSES. MISSED.
AND SUTER, AND GREGOER
HE
I MENTIONED, HE HAS TO START
USING HIS FEET AND HISA CUT IN
ON WEATHERBY
BACK TO THE LINE, THEY ON A
NICED GOING TO THE
NET.
>> Bret: I LOVE THE PLAY BY SUS
STICK,